seul le respect de la parole est à
madame virginie du bim et l'air pour le
groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le premier ministre a pas moins
après les attentats de paris
l'ordre de frapper la ville de genève a
été donnée par l'état islamique
la police suisse recherche depuis jeudi
au moins quatre djihadistes dans cette
ville siège d'une trentaine
d'organisations internationales
genève est aussi une ville frontalière
de la france monsieur le premier
ministre
après les attentats de paris la mise en
place de l'état d'urgence la découverte
d'une cellule jihadiste à bruxelles la
question de la coopération
transfrontalière est aujourd'hui plus
que jamais au coeur de nos enjeux de
sécurité et de protection du territoire
si de très nombreux points de passage
entre la france et la suisse donne lieu
à des contrôles renforcés tous les
points ne sont cependant pas surveillé
et les vérifications restent aléatoires
avec vous le savez un très grand nombre
de passages quotidiens aujourd'hui c'est
du pain béni pour les djihadistes le
travail de nos douaniers est pourtant
indispensable
le président de la république avait
annoncé devant le congrès un renfort des
forces de l'ordre et en particulier la
création de 1000 postes de douaniers ces
annonces allait dans le bon sens mais on
s'interroge aujourd'hui sur la
pertinence de cette mesure en
contradiction avec le projet stratégique
douanes 2018
la direction des douanes tablant plutôt
sur la création de 250 emplois douaniers
monsieur le premier ministre notre
sécurité intérieure exigent aujourd'hui
des moyens réels et concrets
le problème se pose également pour les
fiches s dont le système est géré
directement par les renseignements
français
la police suisse n'a pas accès à cette
liste récemment une personne fichée s a
été employé en bagagistes à l'aéroport
de genève cointrin la faire des passes
simplement le fait divers comment faire
pour les repérer attend les change de
ces informations n'est pas systématique
et c'est au cas par cas et le flux
d'informations varie selon la complexité
du dossier
mais la coopération transfrontalière est
fondamental pour cet échange de données
monsieur le premier ministre pouvez vous
nous donner de véritables garanties sur
les échanges d'informations au plan
européen
aujourd'hui plus que jamais
nous avons besoin d'unité de mutualiser
intelligemment nos renseignements merci
madame la députée la parole est à mme
seul ministre l'intérieur
oui madame la députée merci pour cette
question extrêmement précise et qui
soulève des vrais problèmes qui sont
autant de questions me sur le métier de
l'agenda européen de la france premier
point pour ce qui concerne les échanges
d'informations ils sont trop faibles et
le contrôle aux frontières extérieures
de l'union européenne est trop faible
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
demandé la modification de l'article
16-2 du code frontière schengen pour
qu'il y ait des contrôles systématiques
coordonnée avec interrogation du système
d'information schengen systématiques aux
frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne 2 cela ne suffit pas si
l'ensemble des pays de l'union
européenne ne documente pas le ssd
informations dont il dispose sur les
terroristes qui représente un risque
dans leur propre pays
c'est ce que nous avons là aussi demandé
aux instances de l'union européenne et
en même temps qu on modifiera le code
frontière schengen on rendra automatique
l'alimentation du sms troisièmement nous
avons absolument besoin de créer les
conditions d'une coopération renforcée
entre les services de renseignements
vous évoquez par exemple la question de
la coopération franco suisse et il ya eu
effectivement des interrogations sur des
individus qui au cours des derniers
jours ont franchi la frontière franco
suisse
vous dites que tous les points de
passage ne sont pas contrôlés mais il ya
des milliers de points de passage sur la
frontière septentrionale et la frontière
méridionale mais nous avons augmenté sur
les dix sept principaux points de
passage la présence des forces de
sécurité en mobilisant deux unités deux
escadrons de gendarmes mobiles
gendarmerie mobile supplémentaires et
deux individus ont été arrêtés sur
lesquels je peux vous le dire à
l'instant la police fédérale le parquet
fédéral la police et les services de
renseignement français coopèrent
ensemble pour identifier le rôle qu'a pu
être le leur et les éventuelles
complicités dont ils ont pu bénéficier
compte tenu du fait que les auditions
sont en cours je n'irai pas au delà
enfin
insisté sur le fait que nous restons les
effectifs de police et les effectifs des
douanes pour être efficace dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme et les contrôles
aux frontières
merci monsieur min